one of the things i've been wrestling
with in in the present
is
of course we have been divided into two
camps about everything right and the
camps aren't you know it's
sometimes you fall in different uh on
different sides based on different
divisions but nonetheless there is a a
kind of
um
[Music]
covet isn't that serious
this is an excuse for authoritarianism
right that's like a camp
right and then there's a covet is very
serious and this is about public health
you dummies right and the point is
neither of these things are right well
those those are two camps that have
those are categories those are sets that
are not empty people belong people many
believe most people most people but it's
but those two things do not a solution a
complete solution set me right exactly
and and that's what i'm getting at is
covet is extremely frightening and the
fact that it probably has an at least
somewhat non-natural origin makes it
even more frightening because it means
it's harder to predict what it's going
to do
right
well and add to that that we still
aren't
fully allowed to talk about what that
means about policy with regard to future
research and gain of function research
and right and how did this come together
how will such a thing be avoided in the
future if we can't talk about origins
right and
to the extent that there appears to be a
very credible uh argument that gain of
function research taking place in wuhan
was the result of
americans circumventing their own legal
ban on gain of function research and
funneling
resources to wuhan in order to get the
work done how is it possible that one of
the people in charge of our pandemic
response is also one of the people
responsible for
you know whether or not this is where
the virus came from one of the people
responsible for um circumventing that
ban there's no way
anthony fauci should be in charge of our
pandemic response no matter what
so just to that end let me say i
recommend listening to josh rogan on
barry weiss's honestly podcast there's a
two-part um discussion of
uh of
basically how china's role in um
in
changing the narrative that we are all
engaged in and and they talk about this
and it's it's it's a remarkable set of
conversations i'm not quite done with
the second one but i'm looking forward
uh to listening to it myself um i will
say
we have to ask the question to what
extent are the narratives that we are
battling over
being fed to us by something that does
not have our navigating the pandemic
well um
you know at its core and doesn't mean
that we are being fed narratives from
somewhere else but it's at least a
possibility and that would explain in
part why we are managing it so badly if
that were
shifting our
our view and our approach
narrative control is uh um incredibly
powerful kind of control because it
doesn't require the infrastructure it
doesn't require physical movement of
things in this in this day and age
right um yeah and yes the opportunity
for it obviously exists and so what are
the chances that opportunity is not
being utilized right or has been
completely neutralized is pretty low
chance but in any case what i would say
is
the two camps
are clearly both wrong
right those two camps uh
kovid is not a real thing and covet is
not serious yeah it's not serious this
is an excuse for authoritarianism and
the other camp being being coveted is
extremely serious and the
authoritarianism isn't authoritarianism
it's public health okay so those two
camps are both wrong they're both wrong
right it is quite clear that covet is a
very dangerous disease i mean it's
really it's like physiologically
diabolical right what it does to the
body
long covert all of these things it is
not to be trifled with yeah the ground
glass opacities in the lungs alone yeah
right
on the other hand
it does seem to be the um
excuse for an awful lot of
authoritarianism that makes no sense
right
and in in one way actually i think
there's a litmus test
right that we can use to detect that
there is something about this that is
just absolutely not public health and
incoherent right
not only is it the case
that there's nothing about the current
policy even if everybody were to comply
completely that actually brings sars
kovi to under control right it can't do
that even in principle
but there's also
this issue i probably should have
prepared with a
diminishing returns graph but
the
the fact is diminishing returns is a
feature of any complex system in which
there is an objective right there are
complex systems that have no objective
uh weather is a complex system in which
there's no objective and so you can't
say that they're diminishing returns in
in the case of weather because
um
because there's no there's no there's no
such thing as a return yeah so you want
to show this
zach you can show my screen so this is
actually a figure from the final chapter
of our book
um so this is going to describe it for
people just listening sure this is a
simplified diminishing returns curve and
uh basically if you imagine um
so
the x-axis is investment the y-axis is
return
there is a uh
a shallow early phase that then curves
up and becomes a steep
effectively a cliff face
and then
in which your investment is low relative
to the returns that you get for it right
right the early the early stages i'm
trying to figure out what it is like
what am i learning how to skateboard or
whatever it is and it's tough at first
and then you hit some point like oh i'm
getting this i'm getting this i'm
getting this and then what happens at
the inflection point in the curve you um
you get the emergence of a plateau where
larger and larger investments and that
smaller and smaller gains yeah and it's
not i mean it's not
in some cases it will be but um we
didn't mean for it to be drawn exactly
as a plateau yeah there's a little bit
of it's an
it's an asymptote there's still there's
still returns on investment but they get
less and less anyway the point is the
reason that you get a diminishing
returns curve in a complex system in
which there's an objective is that you
have a hierarchy of interventions right
you've got some stuff that's actually
no-brainers that work really well and
you do those things first obviously
because why wouldn't you and the point
is the more of those things you've
already done the more of the low-hanging
fruit you've you've found the more
you're forced to do things that yes work
but at some very large cost and so
anyway you get this pattern reliably
because a reasonable
a reasonable person or system attempting
to solve a problem we'll go after the
low-hanging fruit first we'll find it
and we'll be left with smaller and
smaller interventions that are more and
more expensive eventually getting to a
point
of near pointlessness
but in any case the point is our
response to covid
does not show an indication that we have
gone after the low-hanging fruit
at all
right it's completely insane with
respect to the low-hanging fruit that we
have left on the table and not invoked
and this is left for instance well for
instance um the most obvious one and the
thing that i would suggest that we use
as a litmus test
is the question hold on a second hey z
could i get my screen back thank you is
the question of
uh vitamin d there it is now the vitamin
d question is not simple it's not a
simple matter of take vitamin d avoid
covid right you can take vitamin d and
still get covid but it is a matter of
the evidence
strongly suggests that vitamin d
deficiency makes you much more
vulnerable to cova this is completely
unambiguous
and
that what's more that people who live
far from the equator as many of us do
are very likely to be vitamin d
deficient during the winter months why
because vitamin d is naturally produced
on the skin in response to sunlight
and so what that means
is that vitamin d deficiency which might
not be inherent to humans is very common
amongst modern humans because of the way
we live because we spend a lot of time
indoors because many of us live in cold
climates where climate control allows us
to continue but we are then
chronically underexposed to sunlight
that would produce vitamin d and
therefore vitamin d supplementation has
tremendous value in terms of fending off
covid for people who are likely to
experience deficiencies what's more
vitamin d is inexpensive vitamin d is
readily available and vitamin d not only
does it not have serious downsides but
if you take reasonable amounts of
vitamin d you are very likely to fend
off other diseases because vitamin d
deficiency makes you uh is basically
immunosuppressive just uh one one
comment there is the possibility of
overdosing yes because it's fat soluble
because it's fat soluble and not water
soluble it is possible to take too much
so be mindful but the point is
many of us have vitamin d deficiencies
in the winter they have impacts on our
health that are negative those
deficiencies do there's probably little
or no advantage of having more than
enough vitamin d but getting to the
point that you do not have a deficit of
it makes a great deal of sense and yet
we are somehow still not
widely recommending vitamin d to
everybody who's likely to have that
deficiency in the winter in spite of the
fact that we have a raging pandemic
um and we could
reduce the number of cases substantially
by simply making that one intervention
yeah so now and there's uh sorry to know
for just a second i was just this uh one
of my posts on natural selections i was
specifically talking about vitamin d
this is the hospital's post
vitamin uh you don't have to show this
vitamin d you can whatever
vitamin d has been identified and this
is just a short list as having effects
beneficial to the individual with regard
to immunity autoimmunity cardiovascular
disease cancer fertility pregnancy and
dementia among other things and here i
um link to a 2013 review article
vitamin d effects on musculoskeletal
health immunity etc etc a review of
recent evidence so you know it's just
it's it's
one of these sort of you know wonder
wonder molecules at some level um that
yes you can overdo it but it's very much
more likely that you have effectively
underdone it with regard to where you
live you can overdo it and above a level
where you have adequate amounts of
vitamin d it probably does you very
little good but the point is many of the
cases of covid that people get are
downstream of deficiencies where they
wouldn't have gotten the case or would
have been much better off if they had
had vitamin d so the question is how on
earth is this not our first
recommendation to people that you if you
have any danger of a vitamin d
deficiency that you do something about
it that includes making vitamin d while
the sun shines by going outside and
exposing yourself to sunlight and as
that becomes less and less
uh useful as an intervention
supplementing with biologically
available vitamin d that would
compensate for a deficiency so i would
say that's a litmus test why is it a
litmus test because it's the lowest
hanging fruit so remind us again that
was just i i i followed that circle but
we're now talking about low hanging
fruit with regard to you know why is the
pandemic response not encourage people
to do the obvious inexpensive clearly
useful things such as go outside be
active supplement supplement with
vitamin d if there's any reason to
suspect that you are deficient in it
those are some low-hanging fruit
recommendations public health
recommendations that enrich no one right
but contribute greatly to public health
right there is
no good reason not to address the
question of vitamin d deficiency first
it's the lowest hanging fruit it should
have been our first our first
intervention and the fact that we didn't
do it is evidence of one of two things
it is either evidence of
absolutely jaw-dropping levels of
incompetence
which is possible or that something else
is driving our policy that isn't really
obsessed with preventing covet
and we don't know which it is but i mean
let's say it's the better of them it's
jaw-dropping incompetence well that's
the kind of incompetence that can be
fixed at any moment you know all you
know any one of these organizations can
start saying on top of everything else
and maybe most of what we're telling you
is garbage but you really ought to
consider vitamin d you're vitamin
because this is just something you can
add at any moment it's not like well
that ship has sailed we can't start
recommending vitamin d now like no it's
not like that so i mean but what happens
at the cdc when somebody who didn't get
the memo shows up at the meeting and is
like hey i've got a great idea check out
how effective vitamin d is for people
who are deficient this is a a
spectacular intervention it really
prevents a lot of cases of cove let's
just recommend it because at least we
can all agree on that right and then
what happens what kind of crickets like
how does that know vitamin d deficient
crickets
maybe
yes uh so in any case uh
when the lowest hanging fruit on the
tree has not been picked something is up
that at least amounts to jaw-dropping
incompetence yeah that's that's the
shallow end
[Music]